[Musica]
Allora mi hanno detto Vieni parla di
cose che magari ti hanno resa Non lo so
Un po' attesa nella vita ti hanno messo
un po' a disagio posso parlare di adesso
c'è un'ansia che fa paura Allora Voi
direte Guardate sta tipa che è venuta
con gli occhiali e il cappellino in
realtà Oggi ho perso due aerei mi volevo
truccare come una a fare i capelli
di Cristo invece no vabbè
però così sembro molto una rapper Quindi
ci sta allora chi sono io sono Marianna
in arte Big Mama faccio la rapper ho 22
anni e vengo da San Michele di Serino
che è un piccolissimo paese in provincia
di Avellino E dov'è Avellino
nessuno risponde va bene Campania
l'hanno detto e allora diciamo la mia
vita è sempre stata molto tesa non è mai
stata facile a partire dalla mia
famiglia mia madre particolarissima una
di quelle persone che ha sempre l'ansia
di quelle signore che si mette gli
occhiali in testa e passa tutto il
giorno a dire dove sono i miei occhiali
un po' quella cosa là noi siamo quattro
figli tre maschi e una femmina confonde
sempre i nomi però immaginate che ogni
tanto mi guarda e fa Giandomenico e io
dico ma forse hai sbagliato mio padre
invece con un'ironia terribile che mi ha
sempre uccisa durante tutta la mia vita
Ovviamente sto scherzando andavo a danza
papà sono andato a danza hai trovato
chiuso quindi il Mood era un po' Qui sta
a casa mia e diciamo che mi piace
dividere la mia vita in tre fasi che
sono la mia infanzia nel mio piccolo
paese a San Michele di Serino dove le
mie problematiche sono iniziate a
nascere a causa di una categoria sociale
fortissima le vecchie io non volevo le
signore anziane Scusate non potevo
camminare per il paese che tutte le
signore si sentivano in obbligo in
dovere di darmi dei consigli sulla mia
salute Marianna bella come è stato a
mamma però un po' di dieta la potresti
fare e non potevo uscire di casa senza
questi commenti quella seconda fase
della mia vita mi sposto in città vado
ad Avellino per la scuola Inizio a
capire che il problema non sono solo le
signore anziane ma sono soprattutto i
nipoti delle signore anziane
grassa sei bruttissima e nel pullman né
a scuola e sul corso di Avellino io non
avevo mai pace Per poi arrivare alla
terza fase della mia vita la mia
preferita
per studiare mi sono trasferita a Milano
e studio al Politecnico a Milano Ho
imparato che alla fine nessuno se ne
frega effettivamente Di chi sono e come
sono io cammino per la strada mi rendo
conto che le persone non mi guardano
neanche quindi sto molto tranquilla
inizio a vestirmi più attillata più
scollata inizia a capire di essere una
della paura e qui entra la terza
categoria Quella che mi fa più paura gli
uomini
già bella Mi dai il tuo numero vuoi
venire da me stasera terribile Vabbè chi
è donna sa di che cosa sto parlando e
quindi immaginate di scendere di casa da
quando avevo tipo tre anni e non avere
mai pace Questa è la mia vita è una
direbbe Vabbè fino a qua non ci sta
niente Invece no stiamo parlando di cose
un po' tristi stasera ci aggiungiamo la
mia cosa triste
a vent'anni cioè due anni fa inizio a
non stare molto bene Inizio ad avere
degli strani sintomi non capisco di cosa
si trattava neanche i dottori capivano
di cosa si trattasse fin quando ad
agosto del 2020 ho finalmente avuto la
mia diagnosi e si trattava di un linfoma
di Hodgkin che è un tumore maligno del
sangue e quindi mi hanno detto Marianna
ti devi fare 12 chemioterapie e poi se
vanno bene starai meglio Sono qui quindi
sto meglio
già
Diciamo che non mi ritengo però una di
quelle paladine Cioè io non ho mai
affrontato bene la malattia per quando
mi riguarda
quando ho finito le mie cure non ho mai
pensato a Che bello Sono sopravvissuta
Viva la vita penso di essere cambiata a
tratti solo in peggio e questa è anche
la parte brutta di chi è malato che non
tutti la capiscono Non tutti riescono a
farsene una ragione di 7 miliardi perché
una ragazzina di 20 anni bella domanda
la mia ragione Me la sono fatta con la
musica che mi è sempre aiutato negli
anni si a combattere il bullismo sia a
combattere tutti quelli che erano i miei
problemi
quando sono stata male mi mettevo la
parrucca e facevo i video facevo finta
di niente Non dicevo a nessuno di stare
male e nella mia testa quella era solo
una parentesi Per me non era una
malattia che come avrebbe accompagnato
per tutta la vita per me era una
parentesi che si era aperta e si doveva
chiudere il prima possibile perché io
dovevo tornare a Milano a cantare
bellissimo ovviamente mi ha lasciato
molti problemi
molte ansie soprattutto sono diventata
una persona molto ansiosa Infatti non vi
dico come sto adesso anche se prima Ve
l'ho detto che non sto molto bene e
l'ansia sociale tantissimo l'ansia
all'università è tantissima non vi dico
lo show che faccio quando devo fare gli
esami tipo mamma Ti prego e spero di
morire stanotte nel sonno e mia mamma
dice anche io facevo così quindi vabbè
ve l'ho detto che è pazza mia mamma e
poi anche l'ansia per i live l'ansia per
i discorsi l'ansia quando vado in studio
l'ansia Però secondo me è sempre
importante prendere tutte le nostre
debolezze prendere tutto quello che ci è
capitato di brutto e letteralmente farne
una forza non sono Paladina di questa
cosa già l'ho detto non penso di essere
stata buonissima a farlo però quello che
vi posso dire è che tante volte nella
vita Purtroppo la vita stessa non ci
sorride ci tiene il broncio No però è
tutto merito nostro dobbiamo fare tutto
noi per far sì che questa cosa cambi non
è facile per me non è stato facile non
sarà facile i miei problemi continuano i
vostri problemi continueranno però
l'importante è farsi sempre valere
perché alla fine non c'è cosa più
importante di noi stessi